hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos
as they come out yeah do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast
this is are you garbage the show we sit
down with your favorite comedians to
find if they grew up classy
or after absolute trash i'm your host
holy coming at you on a beautiful day
down here in aunt tudy's basement it's
nice and warm we just had the oil
delivered
we're good until february after that
we'll see what happens with the stimulus
plan
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he's the ceo of ru garbage
he's got his name on many many many
offshore accounts
but certain investor corey agencies
would probably be interested to hear
if i ever flipped on him but i wouldn't
i would
kevin james ryan everybody hey gang
what's up thanks for tuning in
uh we appreciate it as always please
make sure you rate review subscribe on
itunes
full video available on youtube you can
subscribe there those numbers are true
to [ __ ] roof
almost at 10 000 subscribers shout out
we appreciate it
also uh patreon.com are you garbage you
can sign up you can get bonus
episodes every week and get bonus
episodes of hard feelings where it's
just me and foley a little bit behind
the curtain you know what i mean a
little bit of a family episode
also at the end of every month we're
going to be doing live streams uh you
can sign up we
we get to ask you questions you ask us
questions it's going to be a good
[ __ ] time get involved baby
absolutely we love you guys very much if
you want to pick a little something up
for somebody special for the holidays
you can go over to podcastmerch.com and
grab yourself a clean living the milkman
a garbagio tea or hoodie whatever you
want and how about a nice big round of
applause for our
producer extraordinaire the guy who puts
this whole thing together
makes uncle hank look pretty toby
mcmullen everybody
t-bone hey yeah [ __ ] i owe five bucks to
mark norman for [ __ ] royalties on
that hey
[ __ ] he's coming for it ah gang we could
not be more excited
to have our incredibly special guest
here with us today another
og original from philadelphia
pennsylvania
started out on the scene down there
together he is a very funny stand-up
comedian and podcaster
and you can hear him on his amazing
podcast oral presentations
but the big question about his mind
today is he garbage he's got a real bad
case of the guy we don't trust at work
face
is it really the best way i could sum it
up
and a philly accent that should come
with a water ice and a pretzel
i'm telling you right now this kid he
looks like the guy who read your mail
before
i haven't spoken yet that's like [ __ ]
three i just sat down i know i know
he has multiple family members in
rehabilitation centers
across southeastern pennsylvania i'm for
sure of it
give it up for chris wood everybody
thanks for coming buddy
thank you for having me those are good
i'm not unfounded i am a snake
you are an environment you are ups
philly terminal affiliate
god damn look at you thanks for coming
up buddy
thanks for having me it's an adventure i
don't come up here it's a holiday for me
it's nice i'm scared of the city
welcome to the big city baby oh philly
guys when they come up to new york well
you're actually a
you're a south jersey guy i think right
yeah i sound horrific but i
started in south jersey and then i went
to school westchester and then
i worked in clifton heights for like a
couple of years and that's where it
really got thick
yeah and clifton heights is outside of
philadelphia it's like delco mm-hmm
well that's the thing with accents it's
like the people in the city in the inner
city rarely have it it's like
even with new york and stuff like that
it's the surrounding areas
outside of the city have the worst trash
here go to delaware you'll throw
up yes delaware's so affiliated
yeah but we love it where exactly tell
us the whole backstory about uh where
chris wood grew up
give us the rundown public school pretty
basic south jersey
yeah a public school public school
public school
that's not bad i was a [ __ ] class
president what
shut the [ __ ] up really i could see you
being real technically smart like
you should be like an engineer are you
smart because your podcast
is a quite successful podcast oral
presentations it's all about
like a topic it's like learning that
you're teaching people based on how
[ __ ] stupid i was like a year ago
okay i went against domestic terrorism
i was 32 and terrified that i was like
old and i wouldn't have a reason to ever
learn [ __ ] again
okay so i was like i was pretty sad so i
was like [ __ ] let's just start doing
them
and then i ended up doing like princess
diana on my birthday
and then after you do that it was like
all right well you can't get weirder
than this so let's [ __ ] go with it
yeah
double down onto it i like it dude
that's great what time did you grow up
in south jersey
uh i graduated high school in 2005.
what do you keep telling me that you
graduated high school what town
no what town did you grow up
yeah this kid's being interviewed by the
cops right now he's got the pressure on
holy [ __ ] all right so west stafford
west effort
south that's the part of south jersey
where like every derelict that gets a
couple of bucks
they either move to like you know ben
salem bucks county delco or south jersey
yeah it's like it should it might as
well be part of pennsylvania yeah it's
like 20 minutes south of
like cherry hill so like middle [ __ ]
know where everybody claims to be from
philly
yeah yeah yeah very flyers coming up
what'd your mom and dad do when you're
growing up
uh my mom was a domestic engineer
okay what's that a housewife
dude i bit that hook fine and sinker i
was like holy [ __ ] what you designing
homes or something
that's not a respectable profession did
you know that title
i said he looked like an engineer before
he had me [ __ ] damn all right
he's like ah he just [ __ ]
rope-a-doped us pretty good he came out
swinging
so i can see that yeah there we go
computers what do you do sell them make
them i don't know
he was a breakup early nerd really and
on the ground level of nerd he was a
chemist to begin with and then he just
started [ __ ] around like 1990
and then he like became excellent at it
when everybody was like oh we should
start using these and he already knew it
he was already 10 steps ahead of him he
just got lucky on that one
so what did he work for like a company
that was like an engineer or like
develop software or what yeah it was
like
it was like corp it was like coding when
it was new so like when you need when
coding came around you got to find
people who could teach people that [ __ ]
and only a handful of them know it so
it's like
you would have leverage to get so he had
to be doing pretty well
if your dad if your mom was a domestic
engineer yeah like he had to be making
enough money you know to support the
family
yeah she she quit the job when me i get
a couple of sisters
were born to like raise us but then she
went back to librarian now okay sure
librarian public libraries hello
the thing with those software guys
though like you're saying back in the
90s it wasn't like the guy that went to
harvard it was the dude who had another
job
who worked on like personal computers at
home in his spare time
that figured all that [ __ ] out yeah it
was like a hobby at the time like i like
tinkering on this in the basement
[ __ ] 300k a year did he have like a
room set up in the house where there was
like a soldering
iron and all that stuff i wasn't allowed
to go in it yeah i always try to sneak
in it
my boy had one of those too those man
i'm getting a picture here
yeah there was definitely wood paneling
in that room he tried to drywall at one
point in time he would watch the flyers
games and i would try to crawl in and
he'd be he'd be working and i got to get
the [ __ ] out of there
is he a big dude because you're a big
dude
he's uh i mean he's not a small guy he
might see this he's very physically
intimidating if you see this
but no he wouldn't my mom my mom's tall
i get the length from my mom
i'd [ __ ] roll my dad he tried
i live with him right now from the
pandemic song's letting him know you
moved home for the pandemic yeah my
lease ran out and then it's like you
gotta
i don't really know where to go right
now is he thrilled he can't be thrilled
about you being in the house i mean i
think we're all kind of coming to an
end as far as that goes yeah yeah figure
that out i just talked [ __ ] to him on a
pretty popular podcast that's good he
took you in though there you go
yeah i mean it's i have been much
trouble so you just kind of keep your
head down
are you back all right so are you back
in your the room you grew up in it's
[ __ ] yeah
is it gonna talk about it really is it
the same is it done the same did they
change it is it now the guest room yeah
and you're staying in a better version
of it still got any gi jewels left over
that was the realest moment podcasting
history
him realizing he had a rollerblade
border going on
this is why i have a topic every week on
my podcast so i don't have to talk about
it
so they still live in your childhood
home yeah right
the one yeah the one we started in like
middle school so the one that you
remember
the bulk of the yeah the bike gang days
oh now
how's your windows dude how much younger
are your
sisters we're spread out by four years
we're spread out by four years so she's
four years older and then i got another
one younger
and where does the younger one live
we're all pretty close and we really
spread out no but does she live in the
house with you
oh no she's married they're like adults
that's what i was getting at even the
little one the one that's four years
ago yeah married [ __ ] old ones got
kids they both got houses i drove up
here in a honda fit
so what are the regulations now that
you're back home for the pandemic you
got to be in bed at a certain time
is there chores assigned no my shame
keeps me in check
i don't see anyone that much yeah i
don't look my dad in the eyes you can
[ __ ] look at me and be like look at
your life
i'm doing electronic book reports in the
[ __ ] basement
it's my [ __ ] life
it sucks yeah we gotta get the vaccine
rolled out let's go
this guy's bonkers i need this boom
that's awesome let me ask you this
though body i love this
let me ask you this since we're on this
a little bit of a different situation
but during the pandemic i went home to
my parents for about two months
okay where i was home and it was
honestly the happiest i've ever been in
my life
is there aspects of that of maybe it is
a mental regression of your childhood
but don't you like it a little bit like
is your mom making dinner and [ __ ] like
that
it comes and it goes i think you got
caught in the nice honeymoon
okay period there right and then once
you get past that everybody's grumpy for
a minute
and then i i i at least see my mom and
dad as a couple now which is [ __ ]
crazy
it's like you have a roommate's couples
yeah who are your parents
yeah i got to move out
do you guys eat dinner together as a
family
we hold it against each other when
somebody doesn't show up to us
you're officially code i love how you
didn't come down to eat dinner but see
that's great your mom's making dinner
you're not like roommates like that like
you're not going to the grocery store
for yourself right
your mom goes to the store sometimes i
do but it's never i still need do you
guys know how to grocery shop i never
learned how to grocery shop
paint my masterpiece are you talking
about i gotta i gotta yeah i gotta learn
that
yeah so you don't do any of the
groceries like she'll go grocery
shopping for the household
no for her or my dad but i'll i'll do my
own little sustenance where like i'll
make quesadillas my diet's horrendous
okay i'm still like bachelor eating sure
what'd she make for dinner last night
i didn't eat last night when was the
last time you had sat down with him and
ate
uh she'll make a pop roost pot roast
pretty good
it's like standard 90s mom dishes
it's nice yeah well you guys watch tv
while you're eating dinner
are you at the table proper we're at the
table we usually talk about
public library business okay what's
going on in the public
yeah it's where she works so yeah it's
gotta be if there's any issues what's
happening
flush it out dude that's crazy do you
ever go up to bed early
like all right i'm gonna go up to bed no
but if i'm stomping around late i hear
about it
will you stay up and watch tv when they
go to bed downstairs in the living room
no i'm in my room like a hermit oh so
you're keeping much
like that i got you i am do you have a
tv in there
no laptop i forgot i don't know how to
work a tv anymore
i haven't used tv in like 10 years i
know i haven't i haven't have since i
moved up to new york i hadn't had a tv
or i haven't had cable or t yeah or a tv
nice
i'm glad i'm not alone on that damn okay
wood's back at home this is great that's
wild and you're
are you working right now or no uh i
like got
injured about a year ago okay so i was
like doing pt and then the pandemic hits
my pt slowed down so i like gotta get my
body right and then
probably like january sort that out but
right now we're just holiday season so
it's a lot of
my dad focused on the holiday season
i want to get a camera crew to follow
you mom and dad yeah you should be
pitching this
is the house set up is the house set up
for christmas
yeah i mean i thought you didn't
understand that like
half like maybe maybe mom's happy with
one point maybe dad's happy with another
point and maybe we're coming to a
conflict because it's a cove at
christmas and we don't know what our
house is supposed to look like
a lot of possible arguments there this
is this has come up at dinner time
for sure yep so these two are bonkos
these two are
they've they've been in love for 50
years i can't even imagine that like how
do you treat that person anymore
like i can't interact with these
arguments they're so far beyond me yeah
yeah they're playing chess
i'm like yeah it's like first day open
micro and then like uh
yeah louis yeah exactly lily and steve
harvey are fighting in the green room
yeah you don't know what to do you're
asking where the light is
exactly i try to know when to shut up
dude that's all i go
for man and how long are you doing it's
so this is so funny because the
questions that we normally ask her
what did you do as a child now we're
asking them the same questions at 33 or
whatever
that's hilarious that's cool to put on
the internet what's this well it's
because of the pandemic obviously yeah
and so many people are going through
this yeah this is great yeah he's 40 40.
he just did it for most of the summer
yeah yeah i i was two months then i'd go
back in a heartbeat
that's insane i would live with that
i've lived with my parents forever my
mom hooks it up
but i got a good situation mama bear
cooks yeah mama bear cooks they're
[ __ ] cool
i got a couple of chores you know you
know up to the dishwasher i have to
bring some wood pellets in or something
like that
help her with the pool in the summer i'm
dude i'm cool you know he's just take
the [ __ ] trash out yeah i don't know
what i was bitching about as a kid
i'll do my job and shut up yeah like a
city worker
i keep your head down get the penny
i can do this for 35 years and i'm out
look up when i'm 55 re-evaluate
yeah got a pension a whole nother life
you have no idea how much that's been
talked about at like my christmas
parties
oh dude just like the bennies bennies
are a big topic
he's going on the floor to start doing
fishing charters
well he started when he was 18 he took
the early buy out you know because like
because the unions are constantly trying
to restructure their debt and their
money so they're giving it early buyouts
a lot of early buyouts to [ __ ] move
i've had a family member
like talk to me about like maybe being a
cop recently
really because of the pension because 20
years yeah yeah 20 now 20 years new life
yeah it's embarrassing it could be out
when you're 55 right
sounds okay do you think your parents
would about like would they want you to
be like yeah go be a cop
you'd be a weird [ __ ] cop dude i have
cop face
you do have very you have cop head first
i feel like if i start
talking it would give it away
around here dude all my intimidation
yeah let's get a board i'll do a kick
flip right now dude
you have a social injustice cop face
though i don't think that's a good look
but i smile a lot i'd be a big smiley
weird cop you can't put a handle a
ghoulish cop yeah you're doing about 90
is pretty sick
yeah you were [ __ ] cruising back
there dude i gotta write you up
you're back at home how now you said
your sisters live close by so are they
like bringing the kids over and [ __ ]
like that
niece and nephew yeah they are oh and
uncle chris is there
i feed the ducks with him we feed the
ducks
i take all my dad's loaf of bread and we
throw it at ducks
does he get pissed do you take the bread
when he finds out
but he can't get mad because the niece
and nephew used it so what are you
exactly doing all day
[ __ ] rye bread what eats rye bread
um all dads love a good piece of beef
steak
rind wait you guys have rye bread too
i've never seen it before my dad
i only i was only ever at my dad's house
was rye bread we were
my mom was my mom's house was a white
bread house my dad and i just thought it
was like i didn't know i thought it was
like artisanal i just thought it was
something dadsy
yeah i thought he made it himself he i
remember he would try to give it to me
with like eggs i'm like yo dude get the
stromans out what the [ __ ] is that we
always loved it but it always came in
like a really really small loaf
it was like a little tiny loaf i knew it
was just for the old man
fancy did you guys do oyster crackers
too yeah
now we were never big on oyster crab i
remember going to a country club for
mother's day something one time they had
oyster crackers i was chewing them
thinking they were like regular crackers
[ __ ] took a molar out just try to
check if our dads are identical your dad
does
oyster crackers my dad [ __ ] up oyster
crackers just like that just dragged
or does he smack that's dry yeah dry
he has like a puritan tongue not a lot
of salt he's dry
is he british or something yeah he's an
anglophile yeah big england guy
yeah what's his uh i don't know what
that word meant but it sounded racist
people are obsessed with anyone yeah uh
what's his drink like root beer none
nothing no he doesn't booze no not booze
just in general if you see him
if he can't be sitting mulching oyster
crackers he's gotta have a [ __ ]
beverage
uh a cup of black coffee while he scales
at me jesus
christ this guy needs a vacation he
won't take one dude damn
dude oyster crackers in black coffee
yeah so what are you doing
work what what are you doing all day
you're at the house
oh pt nissan nephew and then job hunt i
mean looking around see like what
january might look like so you're around
all day and did your parents
both getting up and going to work well
we all have like different yeah like uh
mod goes out to the job library public
library holds it down and then
uh i literally talked about it like it's
a gang dude
he's like she's out there flexing she
wraps the block comes back
i love it that's fantastic i think it's
fun it's like a fun lady
like uh it's a that's a great uh you
know second half
uh for like a well you know what i mean
like a nice old retired mother jones
i'm identical like personality wise like
my dad like
my like this library is a woman
yeah i know yeah yeah does he get up and
go to work every day though
no he works from he does internet stuff
so he's at home
who are you tired so the two of you are
at [ __ ] home all day
don't clash in the basement really
about a plan recording time son let's
let's break down the house so we're
talking about a single-family home in
the suburbs
yes uh garage stuff driveway basketball
net the whole nine
no basketball hall uh garage with some
weights that i don't put away and get
yelled at for
what about down in the basement is that
where your dad has his shop basement is
or what else computer off it's a nail
chocolate yeah he kind of made it like
his own cave thing but didn't finish it
he's got a bunch of pictures of my mom
up from like the 70s when she was young
and hot which i think is funny
and living in the glory days oh yeah
that's his lair dude
where's the tv room is it down there is
it on his first floor tv is down there
along with the keyboard
for church music the guy's got a couple
of hobbies he's busy wait is that's not
where the family watches tv is down in
the basement
is it no there's like a main room a main
family room living room family room
then
for a time when we lived in a townhouse
we had a living room and then we also
had a den
the den was tight dude that's got a
little tv in the couch it's a family
it's living room family room dan's bad
news
i'm not saying that that isn't bad bears
live in a dan yeah it's what's just
up for humans it's fun the family room
is trash no calling it the family room
family rooms with the
nice china you're not allowed to go in
there no that's dining room
you [ __ ] animal that's not that's a
dining room no
dining room is a kitchen table this
guy's got a china cabinet living room
the dining room would not be the kitchen
table that would be the kitchen yeah
i've been calling the rooms of the house
ah what's garbage man man this kid's
bunker
no it's living room dining room family
room
not a damn a den's band how to demo hold
on let me ask you this you ever know
anybody that had a great room
no no a couple of my friends did i
thought i was [ __ ] hanging out with
royalty when you walked in there
going are they in a foyer too we got a
big four we have a foyer you got
what about a mud room mud rooms are
trash
just by my name is what you call the
laundry what is a mud room
mud room's like especially in like
suburban houses when you come in
from the deck or the garage or the side
entrance there's like it's usually like
the laundry you know the laundry
laundry there's the build your shoes
there that big sink what are those
called stationary tub
stationary garages also known as you
gotta have a stationary tub they're
tight
yeah you ever drink out of those things
that water is suspended no he used to
fill the dog's bowl up out of there and
come out all cloudy and [ __ ] i was like
here you go sparky you have a good one
utility stock water three eyes and [ __ ]
utilities take water for a doll
i know some of my friends that's where
the runoff from the washing machine went
it would like squirt in into the station
that's what it
is yeah that's what it drains into the
did you ever think
this is real garbage we used to like by
accident throw like a rag in the station
everything oh we've done that and then
the water fills up and it sucks and the
rag clogs the stationary tub dude how
many times we ruined my [ __ ] basement
my stepdad would come home and we'd be
like sweeping water out into the garage
and he was [ __ ]
floored did he get his records no
he's not a record guy okay uh more of a
winston and coors light guy okay um dude
another time too we had people that
would
not put the shower liner we had this guy
from iceland's the
exchange student for the he lasted two
days because my brother he was
an exchange student he came he came from
iceland and so my brother went to this
like
like rich private school right yes and
they had this guy that came over it was
like an exchange program for like soccer
players he was like this really good
icelandic soccer player donnie hello and
they would he would stay like a week or
two weeks with each family or like a
couple team families on the team to
whatever and so like he didn't just live
in one place
so he came and they got him all [ __ ]
drunk and high
you know this is all like real like this
is like the one percent i feel like all
these like rich kids are driving around
in bmws
they have this like european guy they're
like yeah let's get them [ __ ] up yeah
i get them all [ __ ] up on god knows
what
he comes home to my mom's house they put
him in my sister's bed and he comes into
my room
and wakes me up and it was i had an
accident now
i did i'm [ __ ] i'm sleeping in my
bucks county room i'm like [ __ ]
seven i got this [ __ ] dude from
iceland who i've never met waking me up
going i got an accident
i'm like oh [ __ ] he peed or [ __ ] to bed
dude he threw up
all over my sister's [ __ ] room so i'm
like dude no worries
we'll take care of it because it's like
you feel bad you know what i mean like
just kidding where are your parents my
mom's sleeping
you're seven you're handing out seven
i'm [ __ ] making something you got a
cup of coffee in your hand no so
like you're winston wolf so i got it
that's what you made it sound don't
worry we'll take if i'm curt with you i
apologize
seven year old winston wolf dude no it
was more like i didn't want to make him
feel bad
you know what i mean so i was like i
just don't worry he's like hop in the
shower and like
uh [ __ ] take a peek no he didn't i
guess he's
never had a shower curtain like i guess
he had a door so he left a shower
curtain on the outside of the [ __ ]
shower
and took like a [ __ ] two hour shower
dude
and the kitchen ceiling just came down
while we were sitting there eating eggs
my mom's like does anybody hear water it
was kind of like an all-state commercial
we're like uh oh [ __ ] adios fence yeah
he went home like 48 hours later did
your family kick him out for ruining
your house oh he felt bad
and he was just like i don't i can't
stay here so he went somewhere else for
a couple of days and then [ __ ] hit
the bricks
yeah yeah paddy fully would have bounced
him [ __ ] right plus he put like a
sheep's head in the garage fridge my mom
was like what the [ __ ] is this thing
dude
yeah he brought some weird meat with
hair on it
my mom was like yo that ain't going in
the [ __ ] house fridge he had a
two-day
run dude he ruined the kitchen he came
and grew up everywhere
sheep's head [ __ ] our [ __ ] up
oh my god all right all right let's go
somewhere i want to get some of the
basics out of the way
what was the name i guess it's the same
house what was the name of the street
that you grew up on
uh or you don't want to if you don't
want to reveal them because you live
there
let's not talk yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's fine i hit you with a
hard oh there i was like yeah
i don't need [ __ ] letters well it's
usually not the same house man
what about the grocery store what's the
grocery store your mom goes to now
uh mom they both go shop right which
i prefer acme where you guys really
i like shop rights a little better to be
honest with you you get a nice shop
right in a suburban neighborhood
it's [ __ ] a-okay you didn't make it
seems a little too corporate
i need actual shop right points i am
against shop right there you're again i
hate the lines there's too many
they're all crowded together you know i
don't know where to go with the
questions because
wood lives in the same house
it is a little different wait are all
the questions based upon like a
successful adult life oh
no by no means have i broke this
i'll go home
no um all right let's do some of the
basics growing up did you drink milk
with dinner no
okay that's pretty good that's pretty
you seem like your parents seem quite
respectable you seem like
i don't know what happened your sisters
are [ __ ] killing it
they got two out of three yeah you on
the other hand you're
[ __ ] into your leg rustle and your
dad in the basement oh this soccer and
rollerblade
dude i have that one i have is there
bunk beds in the room
no bunk beds what size bed are we
talking queen
clean but the mattress doesn't fit it
okay what does that mean
that means that there's like a slot
where my head can go in
the headboard is taller than the mat so
you can just
you can suck your head in the middle of
the night
that's tough it's a nice bed yeah watch
out
detached garage or garage attached to
the home good uh
attached garage attached but yeah it's
attached to that it's attached to the
house
do you park cars in there no no the cars
are in the driveway too much [ __ ] in
there too much how many cars are in your
driveway when everybody's home
is it three cars two just two just two
and then
i mean my honda foot is in the street
yeah it's in the street oh that's always
i was always had a park in the street i
never got access to the driveway
jamming it up for my step-dad who leaves
for work and like oh
man he's like he's like dude sometimes
he would drive around the house that is
real [ __ ] trash
he would drive around the house he would
drive into the backyard
around my whole house and then out the
front
did he ever did he ever move your car to
make a point oh
no i don't think it is sure i know the
point is the [ __ ] mud tracks in the
front of that
okay yeah that's him going look what you
[ __ ] made that's more civil
like i found my own way out how much
trouble would you get in now
if you parked your car behind your dad
and you were upstairs sleeping and he
was trying to get out
oh bad news i would wake up in a
pan i could kiss the sleepover goodbye
i'll tell you that
like world war z wake up [ __ ] end of
the world panic with like i've blocked
my dad in
so he's a lunatic he deserves respect
okay
i like the sound of this guy yeah so he
takes no
oyster crackers in black coffee next
level
[ __ ] don't [ __ ] with me so he takes
no [ __ ] as taking those [ __ ] your entire
life
yeah pretty much this is like an
interview with a north korean general
he deserves respect he deserves respect
i pledge to him what's going to stab
himself after this i love it
i'm just being nicer i said i would beat
his ass up top so if you watch the whole
thing as a backhand yeah
for some reason i don't think that'll
hold up i feel like your dad can take it
oh my god he's got a ring did you have a
a refrigerator in that garage or
currently do you
no no no i didn't no garage fridge not
big drinkers so no booze in the outside
um okay interesting pool in the backyard
no no no swing set anything growing up
swings like growing up was sick yeah
yeah
was it wood or
oh no it's like shitty wood where you
can move it like metal would be better
because it's more stable for yourself
the highest end swing set of those
wooden ones that have the
the hut yeah that have the the red
yellow and blue
awning on top you know i just built one
of those for my niece and nephew at my
sister's house oh let's get her in here
somebody have a little class in this job
somebody yeah she could talk about the
house she owns
and all these other things the garage
bridge she has
exactly her husband and kids the love in
her life
oh holy [ __ ] um all right do you brush
your teeth in the shower
no okay can you wish although it's nice
you assume i brushed my teeth
why did you not brush your teeth on a
regular basis no it's a joke
dude the rope-a-dopes he pulls he takes
shots for 20 minutes and then [ __ ]
snipes
just
can you whistle with your fingers no but
i've always wanted to
i can't believe you if i was casting you
i would say that's special skills on the
resume at the top
i worked at a looting dock for like
three years and one of the dudes could
do it and i never asked him i was too
afraid to become his friend
i could see you whistling with your
fingers and that you're are you big into
fireworks
as a child i mean we all fought with
roman candles i believe yeah yeah yeah
we've all been deaf we all had our day
in battle gentlemen we've been through
the wars we'll have my venue you said
that's so sincere yeah you know
we've all spilled blood on the
battlefield yes um all right
can i ask you guys go pool hopping as a
kid ties in with fireworks
uh i did once or twice but as like you
know it was like somebody we knew kind
of and just did it and ran away but like
never like
fully illegally pulled up what is what
is pool happening just going swimming in
other people's pools
sneaking in somebody's yard jumping in
and making noise jumping out and jumping
over the fence and running away the
lights are coming on in the house
yep yeah it's a real ever do garage
hopping where you go in and steal the
beer from the garage fridge
oh yeah magic fridge
guy who lives here is going to be upset
on the weekend yeah i had buddies my
buddies got caught doing it
cops got called because they closed the
garage door on them and they got them
[ __ ] hemped
oh my god like a rat trap yeah the guy
right there that's a standoff right
there
uh-huh he called the cops and the cops
uh
you know whatever they ended up having
to do like all this community service
and they had like
like probation officers and [ __ ] they
got caught like it was like felonies
like
breaking and not breaking and entering
but unlawful yeah come on
they were like 15 14 yeah a couple of
schlitz 15 or 14
well then the homeowner decided not to
press charges he was like i just was
just trying to be
like kind of a dick and like prove a
point okay and then the state was like
no these are felonies we still want to
press charges jesus
yeah [ __ ] some hot head d.a down
there [ __ ] relax
buddy all right i got one for you how
many pairs of dress shoes do you own
one and they're all crinkled
what about the suit yeah do you care if
you had to go to a wedding tomorrow
would this you know i can't go
wrong if somebody dies i'm [ __ ] i
don't have a black one i got a silver
suit
a silver or gray that's it's not like
it's not like
he's got the big collar on the shirt
also like my idea of like regal
well-dressed man is al pacino
he's changing cars on the way to the
funeral
ah can you currently own any drones
no he would totally want one though i
feel you seem like a drone guy
i would be scared of getting addicted to
it okay man you're definitely different
than
than what i am at no this i mean i i
know i'm better this is exactly who he
is
yeah wait are drones trashy yeah nerd
alert they're [ __ ] real
they're dorky i don't know about trashy
they're expensive i think they're trashy
they're sketchy is what they are the
ones that kill people or film stuff
that's a good point too i don't really
want to own a drone
or anything like that i i lost i lost
connection to my old drone before it got
stolen
over uh roscoe village in chicago it
started drifting away down [ __ ]
western avenue got real sketchy yeah
like all right
that's what happened that's what
happened to me it literally it just flew
away from us and i just never went and
got it
you had a drone my i bought one for my
nephew a couple years ago
and he was finally old enough to use it
this summer and i took him out into the
field to use it
and as soon as we sent it steal food
from other people's grills
did you ever go do you ever play magic
grill i got him hanging on the drone
yeah blowing him down he grabs the
steaks off the grill get the drone
i flew into the woods and once it gets
us out of a certain range
it keeps flying and just it has a mind
of its own
probably down in florida um
he's retired got a good pennies second
life down in florida
um i got one have you ever owned a copy
of boondock saints
then i went and saw the second one in
theaters in cherry hill
dude people think that we're really into
buddha saints for really trashy i was
them for halloween one year i'm not
gonna lie
it was like freshman year of college
maybe or thank you yeah
yeah had the tattoo on the hand though
whatever yeah i'm not even
irish i'm not even irish at all yeah do
you own any slippers
no not that i maintain why why did you i
bought like
one-off pairs of slippers and then just
left them places okay
fair enough what was the last meal you
made
shrimp and goat cheese and sriracha
mixed together in the middle of the
night
really there's goat cheese readily
available at the wood in the woods i do
my own
foraging
was it cold shrimp or hot shrimp well it
was frozen shrimp
and then you got to microwave it they
they say you got to defrost it with a
meal at night you just put that [ __ ] in
on high for like 10 minutes until it
gets red
and then while that's happening you mix
up goat cheese and eggs
it's the one thing i know how to make
microwave shrimp
purely frozen that's trashy don't look
at us
i didn't know what i was saying i didn't
know this is weird is that weird to do
yeah you microwave three
guys we draw the line at bacon here
that's question oh
man yeah it can't be microwaving so
these are so these are uncooked
frozen frozen yeah and you cook them in
the microwave until they turn and you
said red
yeah you put them in a bowl i like a
medium rare you put them in a bowl and
then yeah they turn
wow you gauge it by sight and you gotta
boil those buddy
you gotta drink you gotta break out a
pot for those
holy [ __ ] microwave shrimp in the middle
of the night
trying to class it up with some goat
cheese so it's not give the goat cheese
credit you know
who's picking that up somewhere yeah we
got something juicing
i think that was it yeah what was it i
think it was your phone maybe no
the second you touched it it stopped
that's true um
just mark that time wise and we can just
clip that out thank you um
all right all right all right i got one
let's start
well what's your middle name james ooh
mama james myself
yeah touche mr wood good student in high
school
uh not as good as i should have been not
as good as you should because i would
imagine you're intelligent
it's one of those things where like like
if you apply yourself thing
one of those guys like a learner that
isn't really taught
like i don't know i like listening i'd
like to retract my previous statement
thank you please don't make me explain
why i'm talking from heart
i am not what did you get in your sats
though
oh 11.50 yeah not bad pretty good
did you understand the math at all i
remember coming to the math and being
like
i was no no i was i i had already
retired from my education at that point
although i kept working for several
years after unfortunately
did you go to college yeah i went to
westchester you went to graduated
yeah nice nice okay degree in
uh it's uh polly saw in the spanish
i fused the two together into one
because they were just like yeah just
gotta [ __ ] at it no i used to be able to
okay that's pretty good though but i
didn't learn it from a book i learned
it's i had a girlfriend who spoke
spanish
ah at the time yeah and she didn't speak
any english so like
i could do oral presentations in spanish
really well but i couldn't read it or
write it but you can't fail that guy
yeah that's true see make sense push
them through
i get it c's for degrees baby i couldn't
i couldn't graduate i didn't have enough
400 level credits
in spanish so they started a study
abroad program in costa rica
it was the first year so i paid my way
to go down there because i knew they
couldn't fail me if i went
costa rica this guy is pretty good go
back with these 400 level credits if i
pay my way down they can't fail they
can't
have seven kids you got to sell the
program next to you right damn
where would you guys go on vacation when
you were a kid
uh like ocean city down the shore a
couple days new jersey couple of
disney's
disney world disneyland uh florida
couple of disney's
florida and then yeah my uh and then
disneyland was
where my little sister was conceived ooh
disneyland i don't know what is the
difference i'd ever land florida's
disney world disneyland's in california
disneyland is yeah california so you've
been the both
yeah i've been to both wow trash and
aristocrats holy [ __ ]
that's garbage it takes a little bit of
money it's that's like [ __ ]
20 grand i know but why would you go to
one when you go to the other
people i think going to duels you've
never went
no that's why you're upset about it
what's california on dad business trip
ah there you go
[ __ ] there we go it's all coming back
pretty good yeah has your mom ever cut
your hair
yep oh like recently during the day
no i did uh you do bowl cuts yeah and uh
grandma would cut hair
for a while too coming up okay so i
saved money my sister caught her kids
here would you have to go to your
grandma's or would she come to your
place
oh i would love to go to my grandma's
house to get a haircut and
a compliments of cheek pinches called a
day i was like six well it was great
have you ever owned a strobe light
yeah high school i don't remember one
yeah you get to order those off the
internet
yeah i got mine at spencer's oh it's
trash
yeah are there any posters on your wall
right now no
you said something else exactly quickly
he sounds upset about that
like they made you take down your
footloose posters i don't want to get
comfortable that's the thing dude
i don't want to make it anything like a
nice place is your bedroom carpeted
yeah is the bathroom carpeted no has it
ever been
no no there's bath mats okay how close
is your bedroom to your parents bedroom
right there
they watch tv in their room at night i
don't know what they do
he's a loud lover i try not to think
about it i go bad
oh my god
kevin um okay i gotta i got a
hypothetical here if you want a hundred
thousand dollars in the lottery today
what would be the first car you bought
20 hundred fit stay loyal
yeah okay if you haven't died on me what
would be your last meal
if you were being executed
there's gonna be sherbet in there i know
sure
oh man it's going to be a list but we've
got to put sherbet on there first
dude what lunatic it's sherbert as their
final meal
no that's a portion of it you end with
sherbet still even in it
were you a sherby family growing up yeah
i think so that was dessert with sherbet
yeah
big time and sherbet tricks you're
thinking it's healthy too that you could
fill a popcorn bowl with sherbet and eat
it and you feel
at least a little to the lighter
brother i'm a big sherby guy yeah
out the bucket with the handle oh yeah
you go buck it a bucket lasts about
three days
do you guys go orange or do you go
rainbow you go rainbow
and you eat it in the dark so it's a
surprise
you ready for saturday night dude
sleepover
holy [ __ ] don't meet my dad they're a
green one too i feel like i had a green
green in the rainbow it's green no
there's green
there's orange and then rainbow i feel
like there's
maroon there's like a pink i've never
had that my favorite to hit like a
raspberry that gets them on the dark web
it's like a raspberry it's green
raspberry and oranges they're
is their quote-unquote rainbow green is
the worst one
yeah that was my dad's [ __ ] growing up i
was like i want ice cream and if there
was no ice cream in that i was like
it was like medicinal i don't know but
there's gonna be sherbet involved that's
insane dude
that's what would be the main dish
some sort of uh meat goat cheese
sriracha
some kind of microwave you put that
shrimp in there give me some shrimp at
the end
oh god holy [ __ ] um all right this is
from uh patreon this is from jeff
paciol uh how did you organize the cds
in your car did you care
or do you currently have a cd sleeve on
the sun visor
so back in the do you have do you have
cds in your car now are you still my cd
player broke almost immediately when i
bought the vehicle okay
the way he said vehicle the way you said
vehicle
makes me think that you've been the dmv
cord
your honor i did not see the vehicle
when it approached the ah there's
nothing better with trash people trying
to start talking technical yeah
or legal like they know the law yeah you
put a column well that's a 3254. that's
what you do
your honor i was in my vehicle heading
westbound
that's big on a burn and you guys burn
cds you guys burn cds for girls
i don't even know i couldn't do it oh
even as a young man no i could i was
tapes when i was young it was tapes
we'd make mixtapes would you make tapes
for babes though yeah
for babes yeah oh man if that's not the
name of the episode
tapes for babes what a couple uh what
are a couple of hits that would be on
tapes for babes
i would tell you so this is this is
probably seventh or eighth grade so
um i was a big pop guy i hadn't really
gotten into classic rock yet obviously
uh our turn to the music hadn't happened
yet it was still
pre-pre-92 hey funk master flex
richard marks um who the [ __ ] is richard
martin you know richard martin no i
don't
i was polite about it not like i knew
what the [ __ ] that old man is [ __ ] i
can't think of the name it's like not
i'll be there from you
that's the friends richard marks depeche
mode uh
sound of silence uh there'd be some
culture club on there
some george michael's faith that's fun
keeping it light i can't remember the
[ __ ] richard mark's song
um there'd be some don henley end of the
innocence
some phil collins late 80s would be on
there it was usually
genesis genesis a little bit put genesis
on a mixtape it would either be
a a breakup mix that like the girl broke
up with me so i gave her a tape
or it was like a lovey-dovey tape for
the summer that
that i would make for you ever get any
phone calls after a breakup tape did the
breakup tape ever work and bring them
back
baby i know you're getting a man
i was fast driving me crazy i can't
think of this richard mark song it was
like a famous song
it's a real slow hit like i'll be there
for you or one more try
was it your opener of your table is that
why you're thinking how
that was that that was the the big one
m-a-r-k or m-a-r-x
m-a-r-x richard marks grammy
award-winning
know the song i'm telling you i can't
wait to fall in love with you
biggest hit limitless no that was 20.
he's got some new stuff 20 20. put
merchant mark's biggest hit
he was married to daisy fuentes i
corumba not too
now and forever i'll be right here
waiting for you i'll be right here
waiting for wherever you go oh my god
thinking that she'd come back never came
back slicking your hair back like a real
somebody just hear it i could have swore
i just heard the music no it's
it's a it's a [ __ ] siren outside
you're looking at me like i'm [ __ ]
the sound of
i was about to start crying is she here
daddy i still love stephanie we're a
slow dance let's go
would you really seventh and eighth
grade but now would you initiate at
uh you know slow dance time seven years
like no i think every
team every seventh grade boy was
petrified of it yeah that's your fine i
would i would all my other friends would
like be
outgoing they'd go out they'd fast dance
i could never do that
the [ __ ] thing you could only do it
when it was crowded enough where you
weren't i wouldn't do it at all my
social anxiety was too bad i could not
do it i would just stand in the corner
and try to look cool and then over by
the punch bowl
who's the fact you're hanging out by the
cookies you got any more subs
by the fruitopia machine
where is he at
is the manager here meanwhile he's
hiding his little middle school boner
my heart will go on you tucked tucked a
boner talking
grinding in seventh grade by the way wow
we were bumping and grinding you were by
the frootopia machine
i got in there we just established
three rides in me no and i would wait
and i would build up to i would build up
the courage
and i would ask one girl to slow dance
before the end of the dance
nice well it was big for us we didn't
have day i mean i guess seventh grade we
had one i guess you had one a year maybe
we used to have catholic school dances
when i was a kid yeah
cyo would put it on and when you were a
public school kid
and you went to the [ __ ] catholic
school dances there was always going to
be a fight there was
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that was
the same with us i think that's why boys
fight at dances they don't look like
idiots [ __ ]
being all insecure yeah i'd rather get
beat up than to try to do the [ __ ]
macarena
he was a great point yeah dude i saw
that when i saw that limbo pole came
out then having your friends watch you
move your hips
that's way worse
we did skating parties too we had
skating parties
like one every marketing period would be
like you know four a year or something
fifth sixth grade and skit and skating
with a girl was big you would like
her she would ask a friend like it would
be like i was gonna do it it was like
the u.n
organizing it you know what i mean like
would you skate with tiffany later
i was that guy too i would i would i
would i would keep the roller skates on
but i would like hang out over by the
snack bar
well i never went out on the floor never
once i was an arc
guy you went snapping i'd go to the
arcade we respected each other's tribes
like snack kids i was moving and shaking
doing the backwards
everything slapping hands too socially
anxious and too uncoordinated at the
time
really you seem like a cool guy and i'll
tell you what
shout out to roller rink pizza roll
delicious all right hmm what else you
got
uh i don't got much man to be honest
with you i think i've pretty much uh
i go i settle my case do you have a
detached snow
plow in the front yard of your house is
there any cars that don't run out there
there's got to there i'm seeing
something in front of your garage that
shouldn't be there
there's some old bikes or maybe some
wood is there some plywood
that never got there's a lot of fitness
equipment that i don't use that's
just all over the place that outside of
the home like sometimes
oh my god i had a tire in the back for a
minute rings
it made [ __ ] rings in the lawn oh
your dad was probably pissed you killed
the lawn
a tire in the back i wasn't young either
two weeks ago what do you mean all right
that's hurtful
what was the tire from was it off your
car no it's a truck tire you go to a
truck stop to get it
for that crossfit [ __ ] you get it for
free
yeah you've got any tires down here dude
put it in the back of your honda fit and
they were happy to see me they were like
yes sir yes sir
i can picture your dad what's that for
sitting in the backyard
we used to do something with tires that
was pretty trashy is they would take
tires
uh in the early 80s they would invert
them and you would make a flower
pot out of them oh they would turn them
inside out that was big yeah
that's trash i like that garbage i have
a question for all three of you
seasonal question have you ever gone
with your family and cut down
your own christmas tree like knock onto
a lot you like went
and procured your own tree from the
forest
no we cut down a tree in our yard that
we used as our christmas tree one
holy [ __ ] and it was basically a bush
and i don't think it was it was an oak
tree yeah it wasn't
it wasn't uh it wasn't a spruce or
it wasn't what are they called douglas
fir
you [ __ ] me up with it how can i not
think of it a pine tree yeah it was not
a pine tree
part of the value of the property
it was on the property line you got to
ask the neighbors if you could take it
down
hey can we use this for christmas
it had leaves on it i believe jesus
christ
yeah that's no i've never done that we
were always just went and got them
yeah you know always my stepdad always
knew a guy who
had something going on you know i don't
know we always know somebody that's
selling something
we have like a meat guy we got a tree
guy he got a car guy we have one of
everything
but you know yeah like we knew the guy
selling them or something and then
in the parking lot cash deal yeah go
give him 40 bucks or whatever he straps
it on the car you hit the bricks
i remember when i was younger we had
some work done in the house that was
strictly cash
it was paid with cash there was a there
was a there was a credit card
or payment price and then there was a
cash price
yeah and the cash price was always lower
i remember i'd be like 13 my dad would
be like go ask him how much it is it's
like oh it's 1200 or something because
that's what for the game
what is it i'm like what are you talking
about i'm a child
sending me into my dad wants to know
what the cash price is
yeah that's pretty cool dad i didn't
know i didn't see that
possible ability in case of racketeering
charges yeah yeah yeah
i think it's more likely what it was i
think we got one or two more
from the fans here please um
this is from dennis you got a wild ass
last name so dennis a i'm going to call
you
do you still hang on the old cell phone
this is from the facebook group do you
still hang on to old cell phones just in
case
i don't trust i don't i don't trust them
either dude
you open up my [ __ ] mom's drunk
drawer looks like a [ __ ] circuit city
in there yeah
a whole stack of [ __ ] iphones yeah
yeah that the only thing i would do with
them is take them and throw them in the
river
do you guys trust getting them fixed i
don't even like dropping them off to get
them [ __ ] voice man
never by like a 20 year old i don't know
how they got hunter biden
i don't think i've ever fake had a cell
phone fixed i do lease them so i give
them back to them
oh see i never do that i keep them i
think they're going to see my little pee
pee i don't care
take a look at it i'll show you 10 bucks
join the patreon
they always ask for the password and i'm
like i'm like no
i hate that that's the moment yeah i
don't think i've ever get i've never
given anybody my password that's why you
got to go to ifixit
off the clark red line stop they do it
right in front of you right there
they'll take it to the back
he won't rip you off
um all right great question yeah that
was from the too paranoid to ever
to get rid of the phone on the same page
there too yeah yeah every i think
everybody is that's like old mother
[ __ ] [ __ ] um this is from the
patreons from katie woolston
have you ever thrown up in the bathroom
after taking a bad shot and not told
anybody then just went back out to the
party oh
yeah that's my [ __ ] move dude come
back like a champion
yeah [ __ ] throw it back and then you
feel it you're like daddy i got
i got about nine seconds to get to the
bathroom or outside
i was going with smoke and then just
like walk behind a cab or something
remember when i puked right before i
went on stage for like a million bucks
just a little bit right in the right in
the phone oh yeah feels
good you're like rocky going out the
fight where meanwhile was like six
people at the village lanthus
wait you threw up before you went on
stage a little bit i was going to ask
you have you ever it was the it was the
microwave
shrimp got to be careful with that i
hear have you ever left a toilet clog
and blamed it on somebody else or took a
smelly smelly poop and blamed it on
somebody else
as somebody else was coming into the
bathroom
no i atoned for my sins but i did used
to blow up a girl's house
and she lived there with two female
roommates and i feel bad about that to
this day
i would wake up hungover and i was too
socially anxious at my job to take a
gnarly [ __ ] there so i just crushed her
bathroom and then you would head off in
the water i would leave
and then these other two attractive
women would wake up and go use their one
bathroom
was it ever brought back up to you by
the woman not directly
awesome they all knew but it was great
that it wasn't thrown in your face
yeah i like that skater on that i still
think about it
i remember one time years ago woke up at
a girl's house
like after a night of [ __ ] just
drinking like just partying
and i went into the bath and just like i
was like i'm gonna [ __ ]
yeah it was like it just hit me out of
no like because then you're like i'm
like oh i'll get out of the house but
like you live in the other side of town
so i'm like i don't know where it can go
i'm like i just has to happen like i got
seconds
dude and i [ __ ] leveled this place
and it but
we shared a wall with her room so she
just heard me like
i was peeing out of my butt it was
whistling did you turn the shower on
i think i turned the sink on for a
little bit but then i'm like oh
i don't know what dude it was just like
so bad i'm like
i just owned it i'm like yeah i'm just
[ __ ] leveling wait a minute i've
never even thought of that you turn the
shower or the water on while you're
taking a dump
i'd rather i'd rather
i'd rather her go i know he's pooping
but i can't hear it rather than i know
he's pooping and i hear
i hear the violence it was the violence
have you ever puked on a [ __ ] i don't
think so oh
no what a like [ __ ] burning man or
something like that
have you ever no [ __ ] and thrown up in
the tub
no no you got that distance i've never
double dipped like that
i'm too conscious of clogging the shop
the the tub drain
up on top of a poop that was in a toilet
that is correct
i mean it's not like he's not choosing
to do it they're too you know it's
involuntary action
i can still judge thank you
holy cow oh man
this is uh this is a tough one to call i
feel what the [ __ ]
if it helps i was in wawa on flip-flops
like six hours ago ah
yeah all right that's it he's trash
ladies and gentlemen the guy's trash
[ __ ] 100 usda prime
garbagio yeah holy [ __ ]
you're that dad i'm coming home
we did it dad that's my son right there
lives upstairs now buddy we love you
that was absolutely [ __ ] famous
so fun dude what an interesting peek
into the life of chris wood i love it
uh is there anything you want the folks
out there to know what do you got coming
up other than uh
make sure they check out oral
presentations no that's about it thanks
thanks for listening
yeah check out our presentation if you
got a second it's a fantastic podcast
buddy we're happy to have you here this
was awesome yeah
what do you got for the gang as always
please make sure you review subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
uh also patreon.com like we said a lot
of [ __ ] great content is going up
here uh we appreciate all the support
honestly it [ __ ] means the world to
us thank you so much for [ __ ]
supporting us as we get this off the
ground
uh matt kevin rank comedy on all social
media check it out
and shout out to that facebook group you
guys are [ __ ] facebook group is
[ __ ] cooking
yeah absolutely love you shout out to
our producer extraordinaire
toby mcmullen t-bone hey
thanks for tuning in guys tell a friend
if you got a favorite app or a clip drop
it in your group text
spread the [ __ ] word yeah toby's
looking to get paid and we ain't got no
games and if you're looking for a good
potato pancake go to c zilinski
over there in rosemont not old town the
old town location
sucks go to rosemont goodbye everybody